"The worse case scenario is that Britain ends
up as a kind of Singapore on the Edge of Europe,
competing on the basis of deregulation."
"I'm Frances O’Grady.
I'm the General Secretary of the TUC, which is the umbrella organization for trade unions in the UK."
"For me Brexit represents a real risk to workers' jobs, their livelihoods and their rights at work."
"Let's be brave, let's think big and let's
organize."
"The prime minister is very keen on red lines.
She's got lots of them.
She's ruled out staying in the customs union and in the single market, which would protect jobs."
"My argument is that working people across
Europe have an interest in defending a level
playing field on workers rights.
What we don’t want to see is firms using
British workers to undercut German or French workers
and end up in a race to the bottom."
"I met Mr. Barnier today and his message was
very clear that if the prime minister of Britain
sticks to her red lines, of coming out of
the single market and customs union,
then all we're left with is the option of a free trade deal,
and that poses real threats to workers' rights,
their livelihoods and their jobs."
"Some of the hard Brexiteers including in
the Conservative Party see Brexit as an opportunity
to slash and burn rights and standards that
trade unionists have fought for over generations.
And our job is to stop them.
These rights that we combine together as unions
across Europe to win, like maternity rights,
equal pay for work of equal value, these are
rights that really matter."
"I think we have to make compromises, and
that's also because when I look at the alternatives,
whose rules would I rather play by?
I would rather play by the rules of the single
market and the customs union – imperfect
though it may be – than be told by President
Trump what should happen to our steel industry."